sometimes it's just not your
day you guys are so like you guys are so
I'm about to leave maybe you're not
getting along with your teammates or
maybe you're getting absolutely stomped
whatever the case may be sometimes you
need to decide is playing out the
remainder of this
match really worth your time luckily
most competitive games give you the
option to surrender and quit oh my God
my level okay I'm done I'm done I'm done
FF FF I'm done we literally all tried to
FF just FF again FF again please please
no I'm
trapped no
f a failed 4 to1 surrender vote in
ranked had like a 97% loss rate this is
an extremely high number where like I
saw it I was like as the guy who says no
on the surrender vote I get it I accept
so at what point is there no longer a
reason to play out a match is it really
worth it to try and fight an uphill
battle and grind your way to an unlikely
comeback or should you always just vote
Yes and GG go
next just FF goet I don't care
FF
okay so before we start talking about
surrendering in some of your favorite
games check out our new merch collection
like our onward and forward shirt over
at shop. thescore.com all right so most
team-based competitive games offer some
form of surrender or forfeiting feature
League of Legends valerant CS2 Rainbow 6
hell even rocket League most games have
some form of surrender mechanism for
when things go wrong now depending on
the game you usually have to wait until
a certain point in the match before
you're allowed to call the vote for
example in League of Legends it's time
based at 15 minutes while in valerent
it's any point Beyond round five some
games like rocket League are even
willing to help save your weak mental
sooner by allowing you to FF only a
minute and a half into the match other
games like Street Fighter 6 require both
players to vote on a no contest ruling
if the server detects a bad connection
now in the world of Esports surrendering
is actually pretty uncommon when there's
money on the line you typically won't
see teams just roll over and give up but
that's not to say that it's never
happened before that's going to be Coro
picking up a kale and EDG are now two
turrets deep diving SKT in their base 28
to 5 30 minutes in EDG doing whatever
they want at this point the SKT forced
to surrender there's no way they're
coming back there surrendering in Pro
matches is extremely rare and nowadays
there's a good chance that teams would
get fined for it due to all of these
sponsorship obligations tied to each and
every broadcast it's technically allowed
but in recent years most instances of
teams forfeiting have been the result of
a mistake or a misclick outside of DOTA
at this point players and teams just
accept their fate and play out the
remainder of a match no matter how bad
things look but obviously what the pros
experience is very different than what
you or I experience in our average
everyday games players can throw up
surrender votes in matchmaking but
depending on what game you play the
results of these votes can vary
drastically for example in Shooters like
valerent or Rainbow 6 you can still find
ways to win even if your team is letting
you down so players might be hesitant to
click yes since solo carrying games is a
lot easier compared to other genres in
valerant in particular round
differential and personal performance
can be a big factor when the game
decides how much ranked rating you win
or lose this means that even if you feel
the game is basically unwinable you may
want to play it out just to minimize
your losses of course your hidden MMR
also plays a role in all of this but the
point still stands in that perspective
you should always try in every game you
should not just give up you should not
just throw if you if you're down 2 and
10 like try to finish like you know 7
and 11 Maybe you know it it'll it'll
save some you know it'll save some if
you're performing marginally worse than
you usually do that's really going to
affect your MMR really going to affect
your RR really affect your mental for
sure no dude think about it you just
gave up in a video game bro come on now
but then there's League of
Legends just FF I don't want to play I
don't want to play I don't want to play
I don't want to play I don't want to
play I'm missing
everything
a yes go next nff yes go next n
literally everyone on the enemy team
counter Center irelia Kane Draven thrash
C well I guess I don't get to play the
game yeah yeah don't worry it's okay I
don't care League of Legends is a
frustrating game it's sort of how it's
built players have a lot less control
and invest a lot more time into any
single match compared to first person
shooters and so League enjoyers are kind
of know known for having some of the
weakest mental among competitive Gamers
one little thing could go wrong and
they'll just give up and run it down mid
trust me I've seen it happen a lot but
in April of last year Riot made the
decision to remove the unanimous early
surrender requirement at 15 minutes now
this was actually sort of surprising to
a large portion of the league Community
but Riot had already been testing it out
in normal Q for some months and over
that time masked some pretty interesting
data League's lead game designer Riot
froon shared that
96.7% of ranked games with a failed 41
or 40 early FF vote were lost anyways he
also added that if a game ends before
the 21 minute Mark roughly 90% of those
are held hostage with 45% fft at 20
minutes while 50% end Naturally by that
time because teams simply open mid or
lose 80% of these games are resolved by
the 25 minute Mark and once you hit 30
plus minutes games only have a 10% win
rate those who stick it out past the 40
minute Mark surprisingly win 45% of the
time but it's pretty uncommon for most
matches to make it this far basically
what this means is that if you
successfully FF at 15 you're more likely
to win the game you're about to start
than if the FF vote had failed now some
people respected Riot's decision to do
this and when you consider that a
significant port portion of League of
Legends players pay by the hour to play
at PC bongs it makes sense that people
would want to make the most of their
time now if a big junk your team agrees
that the game is likely already lost
then you might as well just cut your
losses say GG and go next right well
even if these numbers show that ffing
actually leads to winning more there are
those who don't agree with this idea of
chronically giving up you're never going
to learn how to win from behind if you
never allow yourself to try and I I
believe very much so that you have to
give it a go sure 97% of the time you're
probably going to fall flat in your face
that's fine that happens but you're
never going to actually know what that
limit is or where you you know can
actually come back into it unless you
100% give it everything and sure you
might fail the surrender at 15 and then
lose at 17 that's the way the game goes
sometimes but I do think that sometimes
the the Leal Legends player base just
kind of goes a bit too defeat us
sometimes and doesn't actually give
themselves enough credit to kind of say
no you're you're good enough at this
game you've played it for 10 years you
can bring this back if you just play
smart you just have to lock it in a
little bit more so yeah I actually don't
like the surrender vote sometimes now I
think that's a very commendable mindset
to have and I try to adopt it in my own
games never give up never surrender and
all that jazz but let's be honest for a
second this is League of Legends we're
talking about and when that surrender
vote fails people don't always want to
play nice players can go to some pretty
crazy extrem dreams when the decision
doesn't go their way and to help break
down a lot of the toxicity associated
with League's matchmaking System since I
sure as hell don't want to talk about it
here is my good old pal Colton and now
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about all right league players
get so close right now we need to have
an intervention because some of y'all
are so toxic that even someone just
suggesting that you surrender is enough
to send you off the deep end you might
give up and run it down feeding the
enemy and making the game feel even more
unwinable for your teammates some of you
just disconnect and accept a penalty
because you simply don't care anymore
you are so crazy that actual real
scientists have put your toxicity under
the microscope to try and understand why
you might keep playing even when all
seems lost back in November 2020 an
assistant professor at the Penn State
College of information sciences and
Technology Dr yubo cou I'm sorry if I
butchered your name published a case
study titled toxic behaviors in
team-based Competitive Gaming there are
two specific behaviors that he talks
about in this paper that are directly
related to the various ways that players
react when they see a surrender vote
first is hostage holding which describes
purposefully keeping others in an
unpleasant situation Dr Co says that the
most common instance of this behavior is
toxic players making surrendering
impossible for others as in rather than
voting yes and going next they vote no
and keep you in the game with them one
of the players quoted in the study said
the thing I hate most is that you have
toxic players who refuse to surrender
then I'm wasting in time for no reason
another player said that it is super
frustrating when people hold their
teammates hostage in a game for instance
Smurfs on The Winning Side refuse to end
the game for their own Amusement example
getting more kills from less skilled
opponents and as someone who has
definitely been on the other side of
that I have to agree it definitely sucks
being stuck in a game where you are
clearly just getting smurfed on the
other Behavior discussed in the paper is
sabotaging which includes two subtypes
blatant sabotaging and surreptitious
sabotaging blatant sabot aing refers to
conspicuous conscious ways of decreasing
or eliminating A team's chance to win
this includes going AFK leaving mid game
giving information to the enemy and good
oldfashioned running it down one player
said that their top laner died several
times in a row and became so tilted that
he decided to tell the enemy team where
he was so that they could kill him on
the other hand surreptitious sabotaging
is when players intentionally put on a
poor performance but pretend they're
still trying so that they aren't
perceived as toxic the league immunity
commonly refers to this as soft inting
and it includes things like ignoring
team fights or deliberately missing
abilities some even go for an Oscar and
type fake apologies for their poor
performance in team chat to make it look
like they're new or just having a bad
game and all of this is only a small
sample of what league players have
unfortunately come to expect from toxic
teammates Riot plans to implement more
changes to League's rank system in the
near future to help players avoid
situations where they enter negative LP
States and start consistently losing
losing more than they're gaining but
considering Riot's data regarding
players being held hostage in game I
hate to say it but you'll probably be
better off voting yes going next and
saving your mental rather than dealing
with disgruntled toxic players oh and
league players well I've got you here
when that surrender vote goes through I
want you to close your eyes count to 10
take a deep breath in and forget about
that game be the change you want to see
on the rift and be nice in your next
game please and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
so what is the right thing to do the
next time you're playing a game and one
of your teammates calls a surrender vote
well as we've shown the answer probably
depends on what game you're playing
what's happening in that game and what
kind of person you are if you're a tack
FPS enjoyer then perhaps playing out a
few more rounds and seeing how things go
isn't a bad idea when you're playing a
round based game then sometimes you can
start stringing together some wins
before pulling off miraculous comeback
but if you're one of those Unfortunate
Souls who plays ranked League of Legends
it's probably best that you just
surrender reset and jump into another
game and maybe say a little prayer that
this time your top later will actually
have their monitor turned
on Rock on shellacked what's
the one I've been using lately rinsed
I've really enjoyed rinsed guys weting
rinsed right now the thing about Rin is
active ver to washing like you're washed
after you get it's true
yeah in there yeah getting lathered up